it's that time of the month again Sony
have revealed the games we'll be
receiving as PS Plus subscribers for the
month of February 2020 we'll be able to
get our hands on these from Tuesday the
4th of FEHB and if you can't wait until
then I've teamed up with my dot games to
tell you about a free-to-play game you
can download right now
but first PS Plus let's go the first of
three titles this month is actually
three games within itself so really six
games this month
here's Bioshock the collection from the
first Bioshock set in an underwater
metropolis which hid away one of the
greatest plot twists in history to the
sublime BioShock Infinite set up in the
clouds which ties wonderfully into the
first game story arc as far as
first-person shooters with light
role-playing game elements go Bioshock
is one of the best and in case you're
wondering all single player DLC for all
three games is included too
the sound design has been updated which
means the guy with the awesome Irish
accent returns so would you kindly
download this on February 4th let me
know what you think to it game number
two this month is The Sims 4 it's been
20 years since the first game dropped
and to celebrate that we all get to jump
in and see what the fuss is about The
Sims is a life simulator allowing us to
create characters build their homes
shape their lives and watch them burn
down their house in a freak
salad fire kitchen moment it happens
believe me my favorite thing is to put
them in a swimming pool and remove any
means of escape maybe I'm playing this
rock fYI the DLC for The Sims 4 are not
included here just the base game this
time around oh and check this out
another game this month we have a PS VR
title pad long last this is firewall
zero our
a tactical forum for shooter designed
for online play imagine playing Rainbow
six siege in VR and you're pretty much
there working as a team is vital as this
one can become stressful you need
someone around you you can trust I'll be
definitely jumping back into this one so
fellow PSP our users I hope you do the
same too so you can grab all this from
the 4th of February but wait I have an
extra for you this month a completely
free to play game Skyforge before you
start thinking Adam you
is about skyforge before you right but
Skyforge is evolving each and every
month this month the sci-fi fantasy MMO
has us take on the Reaper invasion after
the god of death himself a fan itas and
his agents of darkness arrived to
destroy a Leone this event kicks off a
new series of seasonal rewards to unlock
but they are time sensitive as once the
invasion ends the rewards you haven't
unlocked will be departing too if you're
new to Skyforge choose from 18 diverse
classes from the life for stealing
revenant to the pyro themed firestarter
and my personal favorite the sound
Weaver come on the guitar is a weapon
what's not to love here so something for
everyone if you like the PS + games go
for it from Tuesday the 4th of February
if you are better suited to skyforge
download that right now I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time